احمد هزيم ومن حيث انتهى شام ابدا معك
فيما يخص تبرير الجيش كيف يبرر الجيش عدم
قدره المنظومه منظومه القبه الحديديه
وايضا مقلاع داوود في صد صواريخ التي تطلق
من قطاع غزه
مياده اضافه الى نتردد عن انباء من الجيش
او من حديث للجيش الاسرائيلي من ان هناك
خلل تقني ما الجيش الاسرائيلي يرى انه 91%
هي نجاعه هذه هاتين منظومتين في استهداف
الصواريخ الاسرائيليه لكن
المنوط بهذه المنظومتين هي البقاء على
الحدود مع قطاع غزه لضرب هذه الصواريخ
صواريخ المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهي في اجواء
القطاع قبل دخولها الى اجواء الاسرائيليه
وهذا ما فشلت به هذا الكيتين منظمتين حتى
اللحظه اكثر من 672 صاروخا من اصل 900
تجاوزت الحائط الاول للمنظومتين على على
القطاع غزه لكن الجيش يقول انه تم اسقاطهم
في العمق الاسرائيلي بنسبه 91% اي بمعنى
70 الى 90 صاروخا لم تتمكن هاتين منظمتين
من اعتراضهما او اسقاطهما او استهدافه
وسقط في الاهداف التي ارادت المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لها ان تسقط فيها سواء في محيط
مدينه القدس او في
محيط في مدينه تل ابيب الكبرى اذا شاءت
التعبير او فئه مستوطنات الموجوده في
الوسط والجنوب الاسرائيلي وحتى في خلاف
غزه اي ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يرى ان هناك
خلل ما ادى الى هذه هذه النسبه نسبه 9 الى
10% من عدم النجاعه هاتين المنظومتين سواء
تلك المرابطه على الحدود مع القطاع او تلك
المنتشره في مناطق مختلفه في العمق
الاسرائيلي لم تتمكن من اصابه هذه
الصواريخ الفلسطينيه ووصلت الى اهدافها
وهذا الفشل هو ما يجعل حاله الهلع لهذه
المره اكثر بكثير وحاله الضغط الاجتماعي
او المجتمعي على الحكومه الاسرائيليه ضغط
الراي العام الاسرائيلي اكثر واكثر يطالبه
يا اما بمزيد من الحسم او اما بانهاء هذه
الجوله من جولات العدوان الاسرائيلي على
قطاع غزه لكن هذا سيفتح بعد بعد انقضاء
هذه المعركه ضوء ابوابا من الجدل او بابا
من البحث والتطوير سواء في الداخل
الاسرائيلي او حتى بين اسرائيل والولايات
المتحده وحنعلم ان منظومه القبه الحديديه
هي
انتاج مشترك بين اسرائيل وبين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بمحاوله لسد هذه الفجوه
والتعاطي مع اذا كانت التقنيات جديده او
سبل جديده في اطلاق الصواريخ تستهجها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في القطاع لتجاوز
منظومه القبه الحديديه ومقلاع داود ما شرط
اليه احمد هزيم من حاله الهلع والضغط
الاجتماعي ما مظاهره ما على حياه
المستوطنين
تختلف هذه المظاهر باختلاف المواقع او في
اختلاف المواقع الجغرافيه لتلك التجمعات
الاسرائيليه اذا تحدثنا عن المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه على على غلاف او ما يسمى
بغلاف غزه او على المقربه من حدود القطاع
غزه اتم اجلاء اكثر من عشره الاف شخص
تعطلت الحياه هناك بشكل كامل طلب منه ان
يبقوا بالقرب من
الملاجئ او الدخول الى الملاجئ كلما ذول
صفارات الانذار هذه الحاله ايضا انعكست
حتى في العمق هنا على مقربه من تل ابيب تل
ابيب اليوم تجولنا فيها مساء كانت فارغه
للغايه وهي عاده ما تكون مكتظه في هذه في
هذا اليوم لانه يوم او بدايه العطله نهايه
الاسبوع تكون هذه المدينه مكتظه
بمرتدي المقاهي والمطاعم والحانات هذه
اليوم كانت خاليه كثيرا ما يعني فقدان
كثير من
عائدات لدى المحلات الصغيره هنا والمطاعم
والمقاهي اي تاثير اقتصادي اخر اي الضغط
اكثر على الحكومه الاسرائيليه تعطل الحياه
هنا في هذه المدينه او في مدن عديده اخرى
في اسرائيل لا شك بانه له تكلفه اقتصاديه
معيشيه وايضا سياسيه بالنسبه للحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي تسعى عبر التسريبات او
عبر جهود تحت الطاوله الى الوصول الى
معادله التهدئه مقابل التهدئه وتلوح
بالتهديد والوعيل في بياناتها وتصريحاتها
الرسميه مياده شكرا جزيلا لك من تل ابيب
مراسل جزيره احمد ه